hello margaret residents my name is  graham razi and i'm the chair of the  margate town deal board  we have been presented with a fantastic  opportunity by government as part of 101  towns and cities from across england  chance to bid for up to 25 million  pounds worth of funding  to support the regeneration and economic  recovery of margate and its surrounding  area  this is where we need you chance to get  involved and shape that future  you could do that by either engaging  with us in physical meetings  in uh digital coffee mornings there's a  chance to take part in a survey  there's also a chance to apply to become  part of our people's board  to find out more information please  visit margatetowndeal.co.uk  i really look forward to working with  you all over the coming weeks months and  years  and you know making margate the best  place that we can possibly make it to be  you